I make music and I live my truth that's
my elevator pitch me like the whole DIY
thing came from a survival thing I
didn't know anyone I didn't know like I
didn't know mixers I don't even know
what mixing was an engineering at any of
that stuff was when I was in the studio
in the basement I was like all right I
just want to make a song so I gotta
figure out to make a song so I had to
figure out how to do everything it was
trial and error for years and years
before it sounded good and then from a
business standpoint you know you're
looking around you're like okay I want
my stuff on iTunes my stuff wants
ratified
so you just google we I remember me my
best friend we googled how do you put
your songs on iTunes and we found tomb
core which is a digital distribution
platform where you can upload your music
directly to all the you know DSPs and
everything I started out making 20 cents
a month and then ten dollars and forty
one hundred and you know I'm saying and
it gradually goes up it's almost like
you're running your own label you have
this whole self-sufficient just company
going on that's paying you every Friday
I partner because I had leverage I got
the exact deal that I want I think
that's super important for artists to
understand that you know go in there
with leverage so you can dictate you
know I went in and got a profit split
why does this be jumping out like yo he
said he's got 300 K for me it's like bro
like this so like the advance is the
least important part of the deal you
feel me but labels know what they're
doing they know that if they hang [ __ ]
half a million dollars in front of a lot
of these kids faces they're like the
jump in at then they're like I don't
give a [ __ ] about what else the deal is
but it's like yo really cuz now they're
touching your merch and the stretching
your touring and like you know you might
be in a 360 before you even realize and
it's like you know
I think the most important trait for an
entrepreneur and musician is honestly
self belief and I think passion too but
I think those kind of go hand-in-hand
it's so just contagious and I think it
just rubs off on the world around you
whatever world you're trying to get into
I think it just rubs off and rub off in
the music it'll rub off when you're
trying to promote the music and if
you're an entrepreneur it rubs off like
when you're trying to get investors to
invest in the company whatever it is I
think the passion is just contagious in
yourself believe in confidence is
contagious the word realistic is
terrible I think realistic it just puts
like these parameters and like these
boundaries on like where you can go so I
think just I'm not really into that I
think you should just live kind of
limitless and I think what people say oh
get realistic with this that's not
realistic or whatever it's just like a
lot of time there's them projecting
their own fears I feel like on to you so
and I always hate it out just because
it's a dream that hasn't happened yet
just because there's no results to show
it doesn't mean it's not realistic